welcome everyone and thank you for
joining today's webinar evaluating
biomarkers for response to neoadjuvant
immune checkpoint blockade in melanoma
presented by dr. Sarah Lawrence the
director of advanced applications at
nano stream my name is dr. Susie Valdes
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by the
lab group and sponsored by nano string
for more information about our sponsor
visit them at WWN ana string comm before
I begin I just want to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply just
click the ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop down box
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email following the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
simply click on the ask a question box
and let us know you're experiencing a
problem this presentation is educational
and offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to teen your credits
without further ado please join me in
welcoming our presenter dr. Sarah warm
welcome dr. worm thank you so much Susie
and thank you everyone who's joining us
today I'm very excited to be sharing
these these data with you and to tell
you a little bit about the platforms
that we've used to characterize some of
these very exciting samples so let me
begin by giving a bit of background
information first at nano screen we
think a lot about how we can use
molecular profiling to make predictive
signatures that will be useful for
identifying patients who may respond to
immunotherapy treatments whether that's
check my blockade or Carty therapies or
a tumor
scenes and we do this through a two of
our platforms that we've developed first
is one called encounter that enables
both gene transcription profiling from
from tumor samples or blood samples or
PBMCs or whatever the sample type is of
interest and we've had a lot of success
with this platform and you may be
familiar with the clinical assay that
we've developed called the tumor
inflammation signature this is an acid
that was dealt developed in
collaboration with Merck and it's a
predictive signature for identifying
patients who will respond to an tide
pd-1 checkpoint blockade the antibody
member Lizabeth and what I'm showing you
on this slide is some of the data from
the paper which describes the
performance of that signature that was
published by Merck and
what you can see when you look at the
bottom right graph there is that when
you look at the RNA profiles from
pretreatment tumor biopsies for patients
that would go on to receive femoral is
Ahmad and this is data collected from
nine different tumor types here and all
analyzed together that if you look at
measures of tumor inflammation here
using an a site called the t-cell
inflamed gep score or something that we
call the tumor inflammation signature
and you compare that that score to the
clinical response to the patients
experienced either and at the
three-month time point in terms of
partial or complete response or the
progression-free survival that they
experienced you can see that by looking
at both gene cell profiling both two are
profiling you can identify populations
of patients who have inflamed tumors and
very good responses but we also have a
subset of tumors which are inflamed
prior to treatment but don't respond to
PD one checkpoint blockade and we we
want to be able to develop signatures
which will predict response for these
patients as well we need to look beyond
both both T cell
gene-expression profiling to be able to
develop more advanced algorithms that
will be able to help characterize and
and develop accurate predictors for this
population at the same time so there's a
lot of different groups that are also
working on this problem the mirc group
has continued to explore this area
looking at additional signatures from
bulk bulk sample profiling and here i'm
showing you some data from a recent
publication where they were looking
again at tumor cell in tumor
inflammation with the tumor inflammation
signature and here tumor mutation burgoo
measurements and looking to see how the
combination of those two analytes was
able to predict a response to pd one
checkpoint blockade in pan tumor head
and neck tumor and melanoma tumor
settings and what you can see here is
that by using a combination of
signatures we're able to get improved
response rates at Tippie d1 but it's
still barely half of the patients are
responding so even with the best best
signatures were able to develop today
from both tumor expression profiling
from pretreatment tumor samples it's not
adequate to predict the majority of
patient responses and so at nano stream
we really are thinking now about how we
can look at the complexity of the tumor
biology and how we can use the
heterogeneity that exists within tumors
to do more fine-grained profiling of
these patient samples and hopefully
develop better algorithms and better
signatures that can be then taken into
the clinic
and used as biomarkers and so what you
can see here is just an example data set
from a hypothetical case of a responder
or a non responder and how when we do
for example both profiling of the tissue
as it's represented on the left the left
side of the slide that there there may
be no differences in the gene expression
signatures but if we could really focus
our characterization on particular
regions
than the tumor for example the tumor
immune interface we could discriminate
signatures which are different and then
which ultimately go on to predict
response between responders and
non-responders Asians so there are a
number of other other data sets and
other evidences within the literature
that suggests that looking at specific
regions within tumors may be may be
useful and this is just examples from
from one other one other study we're
looking and tracking patient responses
can be correlated to specific ongoing
immune responses within particular
geographic regions of the tumor and by
characterizing those areas with
molecular tools in this case
immunofluorescence are
immunohistochemistry you can gain
greater insight into the into the course
of the immune response that's ongoing
within the patient and the number of and
the the ultimate outcome that this
fishable experienced in response to
therapy and today there's a lot of
groups that are focusing now on how we
can build better tools that will allow
us to characterize with spatial
resolution these tumor samples but many
of them have a number of limitations
that make them suboptimal for doing
further further profiling on a large
scale so most of the technologies that
are in existence today of course the
investigator to either trade-off between
high plus expression profiling or low
flex imaging so you can either look at a
lot of different targets and look at
them from bulk samples or you can look
at a small number of targets with very
careful attention to where those targets
are located within the tumor but there
aren't technologies that have existed
before that allow you to look at both of
these axes to look at with high flex and
with a high degree of precision at the
geographic location of these of these
targets within a sample but an ANA
string we have developed a technology
called G omics
a digital spatial profiling which does
allow you to look at both of those at
both of those axes it allows you to do
hi clex spatial profiling of both
proteins and RNAs from formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue samples and the
technology relies upon detection
reagents either primary antibodies or
RNA binding binding reagents which have
been bar coded with the DNA all ago and
the ala go is attached to the detection
reagent by usable by a photo cleavable
linker and then we can use cocktails of
these detection reagents in combination
with visualization markers to generate
data that consists of both visual images
and then hi clex molecular agents
because we're able to release those
indexing ala goes from defined regions
of the sample using a focused exposure
of the tissue to UV light to cleave that
photo cleavable linker so that and at
the end of the day what you get our
datasets like they're represented on the
right side of the graph where you get a
visual image of the tissue but then you
also get very deep molecular profiling
data that you can explore as you would
with other molecular data and it's
highly quantitative and it's it's highly
precise and it's highly highly dynamic
and so you can really do very detailed
characterization of these tissue samples
without without using a large amount of
tissue so the beauty of the assay is
that it's really combining the imaging
reagents on the profiling reagents into
a single step so from one tissue you do
a single processing experiment like in
immunohistochemistry and then you you
visualize that tissue and then you
collect the molecular data using the DSP
flow the DSP microscope and that's
represented here on on this slide where
you can see the instrument over on the
left and then a workflow diagram
displayed on the right side of the slide
where in step one we're staining the
tissue sample with the cocktail of all
conjugated antibodies and the
visualization markers and then we image
the tissue and then we select regions of
interest for profiling and we expose
those particular regions to UV light
that UV light then Cleaves the photo
cleavable linkers which the DNA and the
DNA ala goes that were attached by them
are then released into the supernatant
the supernatant is then collected and
deposited into a microtiter plate where
we are then hybridize it with nano
string detection reagents and read it
out on our encounter platform so in this
way we have built an instrument that is
able to characterize many analytes from
a single tissue slice so the technology
has been built to be able to go up to
800 targets at once we're routinely
running 40 to 50 proteins on a single
tissue section today it is able to
characterize multiple analytes so the
platform works for both protein and for
RNA and so that allows us to look at
where there are differences in the
biology between the two analytes it also
allows us to characterize you know
targets that may be accessible via one
analyte but not the other the that is
generated is highly quantitative because
it's based on the encountered detection
platform it's linear up to six logs of
dynamic range and it's it's its
quantitative binary data so you're just
looking at the presence of these targets
it's very easy to to do the data
analysis and to do the data
normalization and data manipulation
because it's just molecular counting
data and the instrument is highly
sensitive as well we can detect detect
analytes down to the analytes present on
a single cell and we do that by
controlling the paths of the UV light
and the area of the tissue that is
exposed for a UV photo cleavage but the
beauty of it is is the only thing that
touches that tissue is that UV light so
at the end of the experiment you still
have that slide you still have that
sample and can use it and for further
downstream characterization and the
platform is also very quick so you can
compare
up to 20 sections per day so it allows
you to really get a data set around a
large number of samples in a very short
amount of time so this is just one
example of how data generated on the
encounter platform looks okay on the
left side of the slide you can see a
transyl section where we have stained
the germinal centers with ki-67 and the
t-cell zones with c d3 and then we've
selected for different regions of
interest for profiling here and you can
see them outlined with the white boxes
and we're showing you the fluorescent
images for each of those each of those
regions of interest on the right and the
corresponding digital counts that were
associated with the molecular lis
bar-coded antibodies for either Q 67 or
C d3 and you can see that the molecular
data exactly matches what we saw with
the fluorescent data but the beauty of
it is is that there's a lot more
molecular league bar coded antibodies
that are present in this sample then we
could visually resolve with the standard
microscope so in addition to getting
molecular data about T 67 and c d3
you're also getting data about these
other 18 antibodies that are present
within that sample and were
characterized in parallel so to fully
take advantage of this platform we have
built a range of protein content that is
suited for the common applications that
people are using DSP for today so each
of our our protein our protein panels
are built around a core of antibodies
that allows basic immune cell profiling
or basic neural neural cell profiling
and then the content can be further
adapted by the addition of one or more
modules of data that allow more refined
scientific questions to be asked and
then in addition to the modules the
users can also add custom content that
really allows you to develop data around
antibodies that are known to be highly
specific for the research question that
you are trying to ask and the other way
that we build customization into DSP
profiling experiments is with the salon
mechanisms that we use for identifying
the regions of interest for profiling so
today there are three different ways in
which a region of interest can be
identified from a sample we can match it
up to a H&E section from a serial
section of the tissue and in that way
identify regions that we want to do
molecular profiling on we can work with
the end user to define regions in real
time based on the fluorescent images and
the fluorescent antibodies that we
stained the tissue with and the the user
can then look at the actual tissue
section and identify the regions that
they want to characterize or we can set
up automated rules about how the regions
of interest will be selected and we can
then in an unbiased way allow the
instrument to drive region of interest
selection and characterize different
areas of the tumor so we can also
control the shape of the of the of the
compartment that we're profiling within
any one of those regions of interest and
here I just outlined five different ways
in which we are able to control the path
of the UV light that allows us to ask
different kinds of research questions
about the spatial distribution of
proteins within a sample and for the
rest of this talk we're going to be
focusing on two of those profiling
strategies first the geometric profiling
sample that you see on the top where
we're collecting the entire content of
targets within a defined shape here
either the circle the square or the
polygon or we can do rare cell profiling
here where we're using specific markers
to define an immune cell population with
the fluorescent antibodies and then
collecting just the molecular data from
those particular immune populations and
I'll show you what that data looks like
and as examples of each of these um
profiling strategies and to demonstrate
the power of the Jie omics platform I'm
going to be showing you data from two
recent publications we had where
independent investigators were using
digital special profiling to
characterize samples from very similar
trials so these two studies served as
independent validation for each other
but you will see that the investigators
selected slightly different profiling
strategies for each and in doing so
we're able to answer different research
questions that were in line with the
clinical questions that were being asked
through the trial both of these papers
were published in Nature Medicine in
2018 in back-to-back publications and
we've been very fortunate to work with
both of these investigators who are
leading melanoma researchers and so in
melanoma is a particularly interesting
area where as we're special profiling
may be able to play a role in
characterizing responses to
immunotherapy because we know that this
is a tumor type which is highly
responsive to immune checkpoint blockade
and patients who receive checkpoint
blockade can have very good durable long
term control of their tumor however
immunotherapies can be very toxic for
these patients and especially the
combination of the immunotherapies which
has has improved efficacy in in some of
these patients also comes with greater
toxicity so we really want to be able to
develop predictive biomarkers that will
identify those patients who are most
likely to benefit from from the
combination immunotherapies without
experiencing the toxicity and secondly
as as melanoma immunotherapy continues
to progress investigators are starting
to look earlier and earlier in the
course of treatment for applying the
immunotherapy at times when the immune
system may still be more robust and when
there's a greater opportunity to have
very long-term durable benefits for
these patients really before it
progresses to metastatic disease and so
with both of these goals in mind we can
use molecular profiling with the geo mix
platform to begin to characterize
pretreatment tumor biopsies and
understand how the the pre-existing
immune response can benefit can predict
response or can be associated with long
term outcomes from immunotherapy
treatment
so the first study to talk about is the
one from from dr. blank and from Tom
Schumacher this is a study that came out
of the Netherlands Cancer Institute and
this is Jones profiling of patients that
were in a trial called opposite and this
was a phase 1b trial where patients who
had advanced melanoma but had not
progressed to two metastases were
enrolled on the trial and then were
randomized to two arms one where they
got epilim amount plus nuvvula map as an
adjuvant therapy so first the tumor was
surgically resected and then the patient
received immunotherapy for a duration of
time in the second arm the patients were
enrolled into a neoadjuvant study where
first the patients got a combination if
you Lima Magna Bowl amount and then
their sir they had surgery at the site
of the tumor and then they received
additional immunotherapy and their
regression relapse free survival was
tracked over time so these are the
clinical outcomes from the data very
fortunately it seems like both
treatments were able to induce a durable
clinical benefit for a fraction of the
patients and and the group saw a
slightly better responses from the
neoadjuvant arm of therapy so you can
see the seven patients that receive new
adjuvant therapy over here on the left
and you can see they're both the relapse
free survival and the overall survival
for both both groups are presented in
the center in the right side of the
slide and so you can see in both cases
the neoadjuvant is slightly slightly
superior to adjuvant therapy but they're
very small trials and in both cases
there was substantial toxicity that was
observed for the patients that limited
the number of courses of immunotherapy
of the patients they received so we
wanted to look at pretreatment biopsies
from metastatic lymph nodes and see if
we can use jones profiling to
characterize the this immune status
within these tumor samples to make
associations of
of of signatures with clinical outcomes
for these patients whether they
experience relapse free survival or not
and so you can see here just a represent
an image of one of the tissues and you
can see the regions of interest that we
profiled indicated in white circles as I
mentioned previously this was a
geometric profiling strategy so we were
exposing the entire region inside a
white circle to UV light and collecting
all of the proteins at a single time and
then in the the inset here you can see
just in closer detail what six of those
regions of interest looked like when you
had the tissue and in this case it was
stained for the melanoma cells with a
melanoma specific marker called s 100 B
and the immune cells were stained with
cd45 specific marker and so what you can
see then is when we looked specifically
at the tumor enriched region so those
regions that had predominance of the s
100 be positive cells we were able to
characterize these with a DSP panel that
was about 25 antibodies and we
identified a number of markers that were
associated with relaxed free survival in
the patients at the at the endpoint that
the investigators were looking at and
specifically we identified that PPO 1c D
3 and beta 2 microglobulin expressed
within these within these regions was
associated with no disease relapse or
the better clinical outcome here
regardless of whether the patients
receive judgment or the neoadjuvant
therapy and these are the DSP the genome
express alts complemented very nicely
some transcriptional profiling that the
investigators performed in parallel
where again they were able to identify a
signature of inflammation that seemed to
be expressed more highly in those
patients who would go on to have the
good clinical benefit from these samples
so together we were able to conclude
from this study that in addition to the
clinical response that the combination
therapy may be more effective as as a
neoadjuvant tree
venez adjuvant treatment for advanced
melanoma we were able to use the digital
spatial profiling platforms to
characterize the presence of
pre-existing immune response in tumors
that was associated with good clinical
benefit this was supported by the
transcriptional profiling and all of
these data then together suggest that we
may be able to look more deeply at these
tissue samples to develop a better and
more accurate predictors of response
that could potentially be applied in
future clinical studies so dr. blank is
now carrying on with this work in a
follow-on study called the opus and neo
where he is expanding the the
neoadjuvant arm and we look forward to
the clinical data that he is generating
and the Geo Metro filing data that will
come out of that study as well the other
sample that I want and the other study I
want to speak with you about today is
the study that came out of the MD
Anderson Cancer Institute from a group
led by dr. Margo and in this particular
study it was a similar trial designed to
the opposite study but here instead of
looking at an adjuvant versus a
neoadjuvant trial design all of the
patients were getting neoadjuvant
therapy some of them got into volum at
mono therapy and some of them got the
combination of AP luma matte plus Cibola
map so all patients received
immunotherapy then they had surgical
resection and then they went on and
continued to receive adjuvant nibel a
map and their clinical response was was
recorded so the clinical results are
presented here what you can see is that
the combination of patients the patients
who receive combination immunotherapy
seem to have better clinical response
both in terms of the pathological
response rates at the time of surgery
and the the tumor volume and they also
you can see that the the patients that
had a combination therapy had a higher
progression free survival and higher
overall survival than the patients that
got the mono therapy as neoadjuvant so
when we wanted to do Juma profiling of
these pretreatment tumor biopsies what
had available for us were both
pretreatment and on treatment tumor
biopsies here of the actual tumor itself
and the investigators chose to use a
cd45 masking strategy to focus more
specifically on the protein content that
was being expressed by the immune cells
so what you can see here on the right
side of the slide is volcano pot where
we are looking at the association of
different protein signatures with the
clinical response either patients that
had relapsed or patients that had no
relapse of their disease and I'm sorry
this is response versus no response so
what you can see is that there's a very
high up regulation of a number of
different immune genes in patients that
had good clinical response here so
patients that did not have recurrence
with their tumor and there's a lot of
different targets you can see T cell
markers B cell markers PD one many
things which were expressed both of the
baseline and and the on treatment
samples and specifically we identified a
number of markers that were particularly
interesting and associated with multiple
clinical responses here and so I'm
calling out in this slide just on the
the left side signatures that were
associated with the the resist criteria
response and of those cd20 was the the
most differentially associated and most
highly associated with the responder
patients and so cd20 is a marker of B
cells and this hadn't previously been
identified as a cell type that was
strongly associated with a response to
an immunotherapy that was thought to act
largely on the t-cell population and on
the right side of the slide you can see
then the association of the different
targets with the pathological response
so at the time of the tumor was there at
the time of surgical resection was there
tumor expressed or not expressed present
in the sample that was excised and we
found both genes that were upregulated
again cd20 was observed in the patients
that received ebola bat mono therapy and
targets that were were down regulated so
it seemed like patients
and iron p67 were more likely to have
poor clinical outcomes than then
patients that had lower p67 levels so
these data were also confirmed in a
number of very nice immunohistochemistry
single classic experiments by the group
and you can see here again a number of
those same immunological markers that we
measured by geometry standard
immunohistochemistry and the results
were concordant and the results were
also supported by additional profiling
that the groups did so they looked at
the abundance of tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes and the T cell receptor
clonality that was present within the
sample and again they found that
evidence of an ongoing immune response
and immune expansion was a following
treatment was associated with good
clinical response
so in conclusion these investigators
determined that the combination of
epilim amenable amount was more
effective in inducing a clinical
response than the monotherapy nivolumab
alone for the advanced melanoma and the
G omics profiling was highly informative
to characterize the immune status of
those tumors and measure the changes
that were induced in response to therapy
so he had identified a number of
potential signatures associated with
response especially this role from B
cells and interestingly that that
association with B cells was confirmed
independently in the same experiment
because we had two different markers
that were specific for b-cell
populations and both of them came up as
significant and these results were
confirmed then with the single X IHC the
TCR sequencing and the tumor
infiltrating lymphocyte enumeration in a
way that allowed multiple immune
multiple platforms to be able to
characterize very thoroughly the immune
ongoing immune response so this group
now is working to continue to refine
that dosing and schedule for the
combination immunotherapy and then to
begin to expand these trials to see if
the early promising results are able to
hold in a larger population and they
will then be following up of course on
these initial observation
to test these signatures that were
identified in the larger cohorts and
characterize additional mechanisms of of
immune response and immune resistance to
the immunotherapy so in conclusion I
just wanted to leave you with one slide
which is it gives you a view of where
the geometric form is is today and where
will be going in the future so the
instrument will be commercialized later
this year we're currently running genome
experiments as a technology access
programs through our labs in Seattle and
then we will be commercializing and
distributing the instruments throughout
the world to make them available for
investigators to characterize their own
samples today the instruments are being
used in the data is being collected on
the encounter platform which allows
characterization of up to 800 targets at
once but we will also be enabling a
readout that is compatible with
next-generation sequencers so if you
don't have access to an encounter you
can also use your sequencer to
characterize that data and that allows
us to additionally vastly increase the
number of targets that we can
characterize because now we can use that
sequencing to get very very high
hundreds or thousands of targets readout
simultaneously so thank you very much
for for joining us today thank you for
listening to to the presentation of
course if you have any questions please
feel free to email them using the the
email feature in this webinar or please
feel free to send us an email through
this website the geo mix at nano string
email account and we'll be happy to work
with you to tell you more about genomics
and think about how it could be applied
to your research so thank you very much
on how to practice using it and thank
you dr. Warren for that informative
presentation I'd also like to thank nano
string for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through May 2019 as a final reminder
door and we'll follow up with any
questions you submitted via email that's
all for now and thank you for joining us
we'll see you next time
[Music]